[Music]
manor is packed with disney and movie
easter eggs from big hero 6 to frozen
Zootopia and The Little Mermaid all the
way through to Mad Max fury road if you
can move you lovers it's Jan here and in
this video I'm going to explain all the
Easter eggs hidden mickeys in jokes and
movie references I found in Moana just
before I start though I've got a very
cool giveaway for this awesome the art
of Disney's mallanna hardback book from
Abra's and Chronicle which features
beautiful concept art from the movie and
fascinating details about the making of
the film for a chance to win just
subscribe and leave a comment about the
Easter eggs on this video or let me know
about any other Easter eggs you spotted
and there's an extra thank you for
watching this video there's also some
bonus ways to enter the giveaway by the
gleam link in the video description
below ok quick warning there are
spoilers ahead for the movie so if you
want to avoid those you can check out my
spoiler free review of Moana right here
Moana directors Ron Clements and John
Musker a veteran Disney creators and
there are a bunch of Easter eggs for
their previous films at Disney in Moana
let's start off with the Little Mermaid
because of some hidden symbolism in the
locket which grandma Tala gives Moana
that contains the heart of defeating the
heart and the locket are a callback to
Ursula's enchanted necklace which held
Ariel's boys captive and just as The
Little Mermaid stories only resolved
when Ariel's voice is restored to her so
- Moana resolves her story by restoring
the heart to car at the end of the movie
the circular swirl of the shell on
Ursula's necklace is also reflected in
the circular swirly symbolism scattered
throughout Moana searches on the gem
itself the ship sails the rock that Mary
prized the heart of defeat Ephrem and
the circular Sun pattern when the gem
first reveals itself to Moana when Maui
traps Moana in a cave with a huge statue
of himself at the end of his song you're
welcome it's a nod to the statue of
Prince Erik that Ariel kept in her cave
later when Maui's statue topples over as
Moana uses it to climb out of the cave a
broken piece from maui's face his nose
in fact bounces up into the screen which
is a little hat tip to both the broken
piece of Eric's statue that was used to
win Ariel over for Ursula and to the
moment in Aladdin when jasmine and
Aladdin fly by the pyramids on the magic
carpet and disturb one of the sculptors
who chips off the nose of an enormous
pink statue and by the way there's a
neat parallel between Ariel and Moana in
that both
fathers want them to stay within the
limits of their world King Triton
doesn't want Ariel to go ashore and
chief - II won't - lame' wanna be on the
reef am i Ana's story of the little like
Ariel's in Reverse as marina longs to
leave the land for the sea while Ariel
longs to leave the sea for the land plus
there's a nice nod to Ariel's hair
flower in the pink flower that Moana
wears in her hair and in the movies end
credits scene there's a brilliant
shout-out to the Krab Sebastian from The
Little Mermaid as well as a dig at his
accent in the scene Tama Toa appears and
he's still stuck upside down on his back
he pokes fun at himself and his shiny
song and then says to the audience still
upside down here just need a little push
before pausing and then adding can we be
real if my name was Sebastian and I had
a cool Jamaican accent you totally help
me you would you know you would know
Ana's directors have also confirmed that
Ariel sidekick flounder appears in Moana
and I think I spotted him among the fish
which appeared during the 2d animation
section of Maui's your welcome song as
you can expect there are some nice
frozen Easter eggs in the film too so
make sure you pay attention in tomato's
lair after Maui recovers his fish hook
as the demigod is having difficulty
shape-shifting and accidentally switches
into a number of different animals and
one of them which flashes by is none
other than Kristof's reindeer Sven
Clements and musk are also directed
Aladdin and Maui's rapid shape-shifting
into different creatures tips its hat to
the genies fast and humorous
transformations as well as the various
quick and funny transformations that
Aladdin's monkey a boo goes through and
when Moana wakes up on Maui's Island
after being shipwrecked her hair is all
messed up and full of sand which is a
nod to when Anna woke up with big messed
up hair in frozen as I'm sure you
remember snowman Olaf actually loves
summer and likes to imagine himself
sunbathing on the beach now we don't
actually see him soaking up the Sun in
Moana
I sure can imagine what would happen to
him if he did that but mo Anna's
directors have said that he is hidden in
the film so keep your eyes peeled for
what would be left of a snowman if he
went in the Sun for example his carrot
nose and Moana screenwriter Jared Busch
pokes a bit of fun at the idea of Disney
Princesses when Moana states that she is
not
a princess but Maori replies if you wear
a dress and you have an animal sidekick
here at princess mo Anna's directors are
also behind Disney's 1997 Animated
Feature Hercules so it's intriguing that
Maui's backstory is a reverse of
Hercules backstory now he was a mortal
he was abandoned by his human parents
and taken invite gods who made him a
demigod but Hercules however had gods as
parents but ended up being raised by
humans after he was abandoned on earth
by Hades minions and in a nice bit of
coincidence Dwayne the rock Johnson
who's the voice of Maui has played a
demigod before in fact he was Hercules
in a 2014 live-action movie of the same
name the funny line were Maui interrupts
Moana as she's addressing him as Maui
shapeshifter demigod of the wind and sea
and he tells her that she needs to add
hero of men and women to her list of
epithets for him could be a nod to the
moniker of the people's champion that
Dwayne Johnson took on during his
wrestling days mini Maui whose Maui's
tattoo sidekick and acts as a demigods
conscience brings to mind the character
of Jiminy Cricket
who was the conscience of Pinocchio and
Disney's famous Phil from 1940 there's
an amusing pop-culture reference to
Twitter when Maui grabs hay hay and uses
his beak to sign Mona's or saying that
when you use a bird to write with it's
called tweeting and when Moana lands on
top of Maui as they jump into the realm
of monsters it's an interesting callback
with a twist to the Princess and the
Frog
which was made by Moana direct as
Clements and Musca in this film Maui
lands first and thinks he's all okay but
then Moana comes crashing down on top of
him and in The Princess and the Frog
Tiana and the Vina suspended in air by
some balloons which burst sending to
Jana crashing down first she's caught by
a spider's web and think she's safe
until Naveen comes crashing down on top
of her and it's in Lovett I were were
introduced to Tama Toa the huge
self-absorbed crab who likes to collect
and adorn himself with hundreds of shiny
objects the characters reminiscent of
the collector in Marvel's movies who's
portrayed by Benicio del Toro and like
Tama Toa
is a shady character who likes to
collect special objects there's also a
hinted the hobbits dragon smaug
specifically Peter Jackson's film the
desolation of smaug about Tama Toa in
the way that they both cover the
selves in the hordes of treasure they've
amassed in their lair deep within a
mountain and in the way that at first
both Bilbo Baggins and Moana don't even
realize they're walking on top of smog
and Tama Toa until the creatures emerge
from underneath their treasure tomato is
fantastic song shiny is heavily
influenced by David Bowie and Jemaine
Clement who voices the enormous crab
actually played David Bowie in an
episode of his TV comedy series flight
of the conchords as Tama Toa raises
himself up in his lair a number of shiny
artifacts that he's been collecting fall
off him and one of them looks
suspiciously like a rocket which could
be a nod to Disney's 1991 adventure
movie The Rocketeer which they are
currently developing a sequel to the
monsters we see glimpses of in Lalla tie
originate from polynesian legends of
maui for example there's an eight eyed
bat who maui once killed when the bat
tried to steal Maui's wife Kumu llama
and there's a giant eel which represents
the eel God too narrower which Maui has
killed in various legends the Kaka mora
sequence is a cross between gremlins and
Mad Max fury road in fact the directors
have said they specifically wanted to
pay homage to director George Miller and
his critically acclaimed Mad Max sequel
and there's a moment when Moana lands on
the deck of one of the camera boats and
they all suddenly turn and face her well
hidden among the Camorra is a very
crafty easter egg to the livable robot
baymax from big hero 6 morales directors
Ron Clements and John Musker have
cameoed in many of their previous Disney
films and it looks like they might be
hidden among the Camorra - if you stay
through the whole credits you'll not
only get to see the awesome tomato a
post-credits scene but you'll also get
to see a visual shout-out to Disney's
next Animated Feature wreck-it Ralph -
just make sure you watch the little
tapestries that scroll by during the
credits as a wreck-it ralph picture and
one of them on the right-hand side of
the screen right towards the end of the
movie and given that the row number of
Moana Easter eggs and Zootopia it's
hardly surprising to find an Easter Egg
to dis news last animated hit in Moana
especially since the two films are
written by Jarrod Bush remember in
Zootopia there was a very funny Moana
Easter egg via the meow uh their bootleg
blu-ray that weaselton was selling on
his stall and there was also an Easter
Egg to Mary's fish hook on the back of
Phoenix fan well the Zootopia Easter Egg
takes the form of the slow talking fast
driving sloth flash Morales directors
have said that flash appears in disguise
which makes this creature here who
appears in the realm of monster sequence
a very good candidate to be flash notice
that you've got four claws like flashes
on each limb when the ocean first
reaches out to Moana as a sentient
character in the movie it's reminiscent
of the alien water tentacle from James
Cameron's 1989 sci-fi movie the abyss
and the ocean also has a sense of
Aladdin's magic carpet about it is that
it's a non-speaking character that helps
out my honor and guide her forward in
her quest there's a nods of Pixar's
crush and squirt in the scenes with
toddler Moana when she's on the beach
and helps a baby turtle like squirt
across the Sun safely to the water and
the baby turtle also swims by later with
a much larger turtle who's similar to
crush from Finding Nemo and finding Dory
and that lovely moment when toddler
Moana gently takes a leaf and uses it to
shield the baby turtle to help it to the
sea it's also a little easter egg to the
photo stitch doing the same during the
credits of lilo and stitch and when
Moana gets embarrassed about eating pork
in front of her pet pig puah it calls to
mind lilo explaining why she couldn't
feed a tuna sandwich to her pet fish
Pudge and there's also a recurring in
joke about eating hey hey for example
one of the villagers wants to cook him
as he thinks the rooster is too stupid
to survive which is a reference to the
fact that hey hey was almost scrapped
from Moana as the filmmakers are
struggling to make the character work in
the story in fact the day they figured
out how to keep hey hey in the movie
they all celebrated with a meal of fried
chicken which means that Moana eating
pork in front of puah is also another in
joke about that after two feces Hart has
returned as a sequence where the mother
island is restored to life and in those
shots of the islands vegetation there's
what looks like the magical golden
flower from tangled which seems very
appropriate as the magical flower is
associated with healing and life the
character of grandma Tala whose spirit
becomes a ray in the ocean is analogous
to Grandma the willow in Pocahontas and
that she serves as a voice of wisdom and
as someone who can guide the story's
young heroine and grandma attalos
question to Moana is the
that you want to hear which basically
means that mallanna already knows her
heritage and what she should do is an
echo of willows advice to Pocahontas to
listen to the spirits and willows words
that you know your path child now follow
it by the way there's a nod back to the
brilliant short inner workings which
plays before mallanna when Moore yells
at the ocean fish pian you all day and
also when she thinks she's found a warm
current in the sea but it's actually
just because Maui's peed in it if you
remember in inner workings there's a
funny moment when the main character
runs into the sea and we see his bladder
give a big smile and sigh a cheeky joke
about poor peeing in the sea as you'd
expect in a Disney movie there are some
nice hidden mickeys for example you can
see one just briefly in the scene which
introduces us to Tama Toa in his lair
look out for three pearls positioned on
the sand just below Tama Toa that looked
like the classic Mickey Mouse silhouette
you can also see a similar Mickey on the
character post of a Tama Toa
in the positioning of three pearls and a
canoe to the right of Tama Toa and there
seem to be a few hidden mickeys snuck
into the camera scenes - they're a
little difficult to spot among all the
action going on during their attack but
here are a few ones I spotted in this
shot there seems to be a pair of Hidden
Mickeys and the barrels or drums stacked
up on one of the camera boats each
Mickey has two CAC amaura standing on
top what would be the ears in that
Mickey and the way these coconuts are
stacked also looks like it could be
another Hidden Mickey and I'm sure
there'll be more hidden secrets tucked
away in these manically busy camera
scenes that we'll have to wait for the
blu-ray to spot now I'd love to know
what other Easter eggs and references
you spotted that I missed and how does
Moana compare with your other favorite
Disney movies let me know in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe and comment for your chance to
win this gorgeous the art of Disney's
will run a hardback book if you enjoy
finding Easter eggs and disney movies
check out my Zootopia Easter eggs video
and I've also got more Moana videos for
you including my review my top 5 moments
and amazing facts about the making of
the movie click or tap on either of
these links here to check those out
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers
[Music]